Tăng tình rất thải là bánh kèo, tục phẩm ăn vật không só gồn gốc tức tục bị phát hiện đủ bỏ trẻ phép tại Sá la Phu,
huyên hoài đức, hà nội, người loại vì ăn vòan bệ sinh và mùi chương.
Ví nhận tại hiện chương hai lại bao biệt sần phẩm bánh kèo có mò sắc, tên gọi và bao bi khá giống các nhận hiệu nổi tiếng trên thiệt chương.
Một số bao biệt có địa chỉ sản xuất tiếng Việt và tiếng anh khác nhau.
Trong đó, một sản phẩm có địa chỉ ngay tại la Phu, còn sản phẩm kiên sản xuất nơi khác nhìn có số địa thoại lên hệ giống sản phẩm trước,
đồng thời có số địa thoại của định xuất hiện trên tấm biển một cơ sở ở chung tâm sả la Phu.
Theo lãnh đạo sá, gió chương xác định được công việc chiều chắc nghiệp chính quyền sẽ thơi đình vì vẫn chuyển xử li số giác thải này.
Đồng thời, lúc lượng tần chắc sẽ được tăng cường đi ngăn chẳng tình chẳng tại diễn.
Đây là lần thứ hai chỉ trong vậy tháng, khu vực này xuất hiện bại giác thực phẩm với quy mối lớn.
Tình trạng đủ bỏ bánh kèo ra không gió nguyên gốc cũng đang dính ra tại một số địa phương khác như thành phố chiming,
người lông hại vì ăn tòa nguyện vệ sinh và mối chương.